>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> So, great.
So, at this point, I'm very pleased to
be able to introduce Monica Mohindra.
Monica is head of program coordination and
communications for the Veteran's History Project
at the Library of Congress, which I believe is
actually celebrating its 15th anniversary today.
In the ten years that Monica's been with
the project, she's been proud to serve
as the primary liaison responsible
for coordinating a range
of collaborative efforts involving
such projects and organizations
as the Vietnam Veteran's Memorial, Princess
Cruises, PBS, Ken Burns Florentine Films,
The History Channel, and the
Department of Veteran Affairs.
So, without further ado, I'm going to go
ahead and hand it over to Monica, and, Monica,
thank you for being here and take it away.
>> Hi. Good afternoon, everybody.
I'm very happy to be here, and,
Michael, you stole my thunder.
Yes. This is our 15th anniversary today,
and we're, it couldn't be a better moment
than to be here with you and
we appreciate the opportunity.
I'm going to get started with the slides,
and, so, what I want to do is just kind
of outline what the plan is for my time
with you and assure you that there's plenty,
going to be plenty of time for questions
at the end, and I'll do any best
to answer questions as they come up.
I see some familiar names participating, and,
so, I hope some of those folks will chime
in with specifics because I know they've
participated with the project for a long time.
Like I see Byron Haldeman [phonetic].
Hello. So, today, I'm going to start with
a brief introduction to the project itself
with the assumption that most
of you aren't super familiar
with the background of the project.
And then I'll go into two major ways of how
the project can be used in a classroom setting.
The first will be accessing and using existing
collections through a variety of means
and with the resources that my colleagues
in, at outreach have created as well as some
that we've developed within the
project for use in the classroom,
and then the second way is
working with your students
to actually create primary source collections
through the Veteran's History Project.
So, I'll go into the specifics of both of those.
And I'll start with sort of how to get into
the existing collections because there's lots
of different ways to do that and lots
of curated sections, and then as I said,
there will be time at the end for questions.
So, a little bit about the
background about the project.
As Michael said and as I said,
this is our 15th anniversary today.
It was signed unanimously into
law by both Houses of Congress
and by the time President Bill Clinton on this
day in 2000, and the idea was to get individuals
around the country to interview the veterans
in their lives, in their communities,
and voluntarily submit those interviews
to the Veteran's History Project.
So, that's the basis.
It was actually originally the Veteran's Oral
History Project but quickly realized the need
to incorporate opportunities for other primary
sources that spoke to the first person narrative
of veteran's experience to be more inclusive.
At the time, the focus was on going
after the more senior veterans
first, so, at the time World War I.
And at the time, we weren't yet
engaged in Iraq and Afghanistan.
So, the idea was how to make sure that we can
get those more senior compelling first person
narratives before they were lost
and before the generations who have
that one-on-one experience were
not able to share them with us.
So, it expanded to include collections
of original photographs, letters,
documents that also share that
first person narrative, and, so,
that's really what makes the collection so rich.
We're approaching, with insight,
is that important milestone
of a hundred thousand veterans were very excited
about that, but it's a double edged sword
because every veteran's story is important.
So, there's nothing more important about
those first 100,000 or about the next 100,000.
It's just nice to recognize that we have
reached a reference point, a milestone,
that indicates a level of
inclusivity of the collections.
What you see here is our homepage and
is a great thing to keep returning to.
Just to point out a few things because
I know it's not always the easiest
to decipher right away.
Our 15 minute video is available up in the
right hand corner, and I definitely recommend
that as a great way to just kind of get
started on how to create the collections.
And then we're going to be talking about
ways to access existing collections.
So, the first thing I'd like to point out is our
blog which is something we're increasingly using
as a place to help share curated
collections appropriate for broad audiences.
You'll see here the latest example.
We have two of our staff, one a reference
specialist and another a liaison specialist,
who are working to really dig deep
and find elements in the collections
that will be relevant to people across
all different kinds of audiences,
whether we're talking just the
casual observer or students.
The topics are as universal as we
did a whole series with several
of our staff investigating different
collections last winter along with theme
of missing home and being home for the holidays.
And, so, you can dig into the
archive of the blog and find those,
or as specific to military experience, but
as accessible and relatable as a few stories
that talked about, you know, what was that
one food element that sort of gave you comfort
in the midst of all the conflict.
And one of the things that we have
found that seemed to be the kind
of elemental experience was peaches.
So, you have a really broad way of engaging with
the collections but finding very specific ones.
I'm going to jump back just really quick to
show you exactly where you can find that blog.
There is an orange button VHP blog
down in the bottom left hand corner,
and then that brings you to this page.
If you scroll down on this page, what
you'll find when you're on the live website,
not on this slide, what you'll find is a section
of tags, and if you want to get to all 67
of the currently curated sort
of blogs, what you'll get,
what you'll find is the Veteran's History
Project tag; and that'll get you to a page
with all of the different topics
that we've covered to this point.
We do answer questions pretty quickly.
It's a great way to -- yes, Dinah.
I'll answer your question in just a second.
The comments in the blog are a great way to
interact and get questions answered right away,
but there are also a place we're
typically asking for participation.
You know, if there's a particular theme or topic
that you'd like to see explored on the blog.
That's a great place to have that
featured and paid attention to
or have your students go ahead
and interact directly there.
So, back to the homepage one more
time so that I can show that URL.
As Dinah asks for, it's www.loc.gov/vets,
as in V-E-T-S.
Thanks, Wally.
Can everyone see this?
On this side?
Great. Yeah.
That's exactly it.
That's the URL.
Thank you.
Fantastic.
Thanks for the question and thanks
for the help getting the answer out.
So, the other place, and here, I'm
going to jump around a little bit.
I hope I'm not giving you, your eyes whiplash.
So, the other place that we find collections and
curated collections, if you look in the center,
right now we have a collection up called, this
is always our experiencing war section is always
where we have our online exhibits.
The current one is end of World
War II, the 70th anniversary.
If you were to click on that on the live page,
what you would find is this wonderful display
with the collections that have
been curated to express that theme,
and what's nice about this
is that we work really hard
to show the diversity of our content.
It's particularly nice for situations
where you're having students try and come
at the topics from a few different angles.
And when we talk about diversity, we're really
talking about not just ethnic and racial
and background diversity, but from all
across the country, from branch of service,
from conflict, from every kind of way
you can slice it, even faith backgrounds.
So, we really try to focus that both for
our efforts in trying to accrue collections
but also specifically in
trying to highlight collections
and bring them to the forefront for use.
So, on this page, what you'll want to do when
you get there is scroll again to the bottom
of it, and what you'll find when you do that
is a section entitled "Stories by Theme";
and you'll get to all of our
experiencing war releases listed by theme.
I'm proud to say we're at 50 now
and 51 will be released next week
in commemoration of that 15th anniversary.
So, here is a really great easy break
down of existing topics to explore.
Obviously, I shouldn't have favorites, but I do.
Some include chaplains on a divine mission.
We're really excited about our efforts which
began about four years ago, five years ago,
to try and capture the stories of
chaplains of all different faith backgrounds
because we discovered that was a sort of
underrepresented population in our collections
in terms of exploring that type of
service within the veteran experience.
And some of the others that are really fun are
stories from the stacks, staff picks, but also,
you can find ones that have curricular
ties or personal interests ties
and hopefully share a slightly different
slice of specifically the human experience.
Our goal really is to look at this from
the perspective of the human experience
as opposed to, you know, tell us the
narrative of a particular combat.
We're looking for the personal
narrative in each veteran's story.
So, again, to get to this next
page I'm going to show you.
Go back to the homepage.
I'm not going to whip through
that now, but that,
you would go back to the homepage
to get to how to participate.
And the reason I want to point this out
just quickly, I'll come back to this topic
in greater depth, but this is an area that
we have specifically for helping students
and educators in creating the primary source
of the Veteran's History Project collections.
And I'm going to make a real distinction here.
We're not just talking about oral
histories, particularly now with the ages
of World War II veterans that we're working
with, you know, octogenarians, nonagenarians,
and also with the predominance
of World War I as a topic.
What we're finding is that people are
looking for what to do with the collections
of photographs and letters and documents
that they're finding in their closets
and their attics and their garages
that will need a place to go,
and this is a really great
way, also, to engage students
in creating a primary source collection.
And I'll get a little bit more
into that, but I wanted you to know
that this page exists for
your benefit and for theirs.
Thanks, Kathleen.
What about artistic expressions
as well as stories?
Yes. In fact, we're about to have an
onsite exhibit, a temporary exhibit here
in the coming weeks, about
portraits that were taken during war.
We also accept elements of
poetry, that sort of thing,
as long as it is that first person
descriptive narrative of the veteran
and conducted from that perspective.
If you're looking, Kathleen,
specifically for some great ones,
Joseph Farris who unfortunately I
just learned passed away this year.
Farris, F-A-R-R-I-S, has a great collection, so
does Mimi Lester and there are several others.
I can certainly send you more
information about artistic expressions
in the existing stories on
a later date or offline.
So, when we're talking about
ways to -- oh, dear.
Oh. These slides are not loading.
Oh, dear. Okay.
Well, I will describe this slide, and you will
help me with your prodigious imaginations.
This is a primary source
analysis tool that my colleagues
in educational outreach have
available through their website,
and we'll make sure that you get this URL also.
I wanted to point it out because
what it does is it enables to you
to choose oral history specifically, and
then there are several guiding questions.
You can use it with your students.
You can use it for yourself.
You can hand it directly to them.
There are three sections.
So, observation, reflection, and questions,
and in each section, there's a pull down menu.
You can either have them do it themselves
or you can use the pull down menu
with selected prompts to help them get through.
And what I particularly like about
it, and I think is useful when trying
to pair our resources with the
tools that they've provided,
is that you can do further
investigation with these primary sources
in the Veteran's History Project by
choosing oral history or documents.
There's different ways to do it.
And it really points out to me the easy ways
you can use primary sources to engage students
and develop critical thinking skills.
A big part for us about why world history
is important and why specifically thinking
about oral history as important as a primary
resource is the authentic voice verses the,
quote unquote, "authoritative voice".
And from our purposes, as I mentioned, that
we work really hard to have the diversity --
thank you, Michael -- to
have the diversity expressed.
We really feel it also helps
give a real democratized voice.
You can have students specifically look
for veterans from their particular area
of the country, from their
particular background, and, so,
you're getting that authentic perspective
to investigate a topic further;
but you're able to refine the lens to something
that may be extremely approachable
to your students.
The next slide, it was an example of a
letter that was being used by students
that they described their
reaction to in this slide.
It's a wonderful primary
source of a letter that goes on
and on in a prose that's
just a gorgeous 1944 prose.
Bear with my sick cold infected voice.
I'll read just a few lines
so you get a sense of it.
"My darling Jamie, hope this gets out to you.
It will be the last note
from me for a long time.
Don't worry, angel.
I'll get in touch with you first chance I get.
Believe me, darling, I'm feeling
wonderfully well and absolutely squared away
for anything that can come my way."
And I think what's so wonderful about these
documents and the opportunity to see them
in their handwriting and in their entirety
for the students is it really personalizes the
experience that lets them see beyond their,
it lets them expand past their
presumptions as you can see
as they're reflecting here
in these student blog pieces.
The other thing that's really wonderful about
it, and not necessarily reflected in this blog,
but I think is easy to incorporate in
a classroom setting is the opportunity
to think about, in this particular case, is this
incredibly, it's a love note that's going on
and on in this gorgeous handwriting,
and the questions that arise immediately
are what does this veteran talk about?
What doesn't he talk about?
And why? This happens to be a letter
that doesn't have anything redacted.
And, so, I know that that was a big issue
to be talking about, for lots of veterans,
they wanted to make sure that
when their letters arrived home,
they were visually an expression of, you
know, them thinking about their families
and they didn't want all the black lines all
across their letters for their redaction.
So, that sends you in a couple different
directions and gives lots of opportunity
for the students for personal impact.
We, just another quick example, we had a
group of students in, oh, probably about five
or six years ago, and we always, when
students come in to present collections,
we talked to them about the
experience, what it was like for them.
We try and hear what they're reflections
are having created the primary source.
So, I do my best to put a
few of them on the spot,
especially when they're high school students.
That's pretty fun.
And they always come up with
these really fantastic answers.
One thing that has always struck out to
me is this one student's answer which was,
that she was so excited to do this project
after, she was trepidatious at first but excited
to do this project with her father because
he had served in the Persian Gulf War.
And, you know, at the time, we were deeply
involved in Iraq and Afghanistan, and she said,
"You know, I didn't even know
that the Persian Gulf War existed.
I hadn't heard the term until I
did this project with my dad."
And it just really struck me at the time.
I couldn't believe she hadn't
even heard of the term.
So, I went and I looked at the textbook that
she was used that apparently at the time,
lots of social studies teachers
were using around the country,
and there was literally one
paragraph about the Persian Gulf War.
And, so, this opportunity gave her a
chance not only to know her father better,
but to understand the connections between
all the conflicts and our shared history
as a result, an opportunity
to dig deeper, which she did.
She then went on to look at other collections
out of personal interest about the Persian Gulf
in our collections and apparently
found it quite gratifying.
The other things that we've seen teachers
do really successfully to capture and expand
on student reflections include
creating Wiki's with them.
As you see here, blogs.
One really creative exercise that I saw was the
students actually wrote letters to the veterans
or the family members of the
collections that they were viewing.
They didn't know them.
They hadn't created the interviews themselves.
They were simply write heartfelt letters
about their experience back to the veterans,
and having it be targeted towards them,
I think really illuminated a human
connection you might not otherwise see.
Just another point on that.
Once a student does, I just gave the
example of the student who went and looked
at other Persian Gulf collections, once a
student or a classroom or a project is targeted
around a specific kind of collection
or a specific kind of experience,
it's also really cool to have them
have the opportunity to go back
through the digitized collections and look
for others from the veterans who maybe served
from a similar battle or in the same
unit or from the same town or background.
What I like about that and what I take every
opportunity to do to share with students is
to talk a little bit about that work
is very similar to what we see happen
with researchers every week
here in our collections.
So, going back in and looking for corroborating
or validating other stories that relate
to the one that they've experienced
is exactly what researchers like.
That everyone from folks from the
DPMO who are looking to find POW/MIAs
and using our collections to help identify
ways to do that to people looking to make PBS
or HBO sets more authentic by
having better images on the walls
to authors of fiction or nonfiction.
That's the kind of work those
people are doing, and, so,
these students are engaged in that similar work.
It's always really exciting to share that with
them, especially when they are able to come
to the building, but also just when
they can see it for themselves online.
Our colleagues in, at outreach have also created
with us a couple of curated primary source sets
with attendant tools to help make them
a little easier to use in the classroom.
The nice thing about these is that
they have been specifically selected
to not be offensive for a wide variety of ages.
It's a great way participation for the project
is really limited to tenth grade and above,
but use of the project, we're really trying
to make it as broadly accessible as possible.
What you see here is the teacher page from
which you can get to the primary source sets.
Which are here, and what you'll see
on these is the veteran's stories,
the Veteran's History Project, and
veteran's story struggles for participation.
Both primary source that have several specific
collections, and then there are tools;
how to put those straight
into a classroom setting.
Here's an example of what that looks like.
So, you see that there are
analysis tools and guides and a PDF
and you get a really broad range
of different kinds of experiences.
One of the tools that's available is
analyzing oral histories, and it's something,
this is also where you get that analysis
tool that I had mentioned earlier.
And this is really great.
All of these resources are shared so far are
really helpful for taking what's existing
and using it in a variety of classroom settings.
But the other way to participate
with our collections is actually
to generate the primary source,
is actually to create an interview
or to pull together a collection
of original materials.
And one of the fantastic benefits of that is
having the students work together in teams
or individually with a veteran, each to bring
a story to the surface and give it life.
There's something extremely
empowering about that experience,
both for the students and for the veterans.
They co-create something which lasts for
posterity is saved for history at the Library
of Congress, and there's something
about creating that primary source
and having it preserved at the Library
of Congress that is super validating
for both people or the team of
people engaged in that effort,
to know that that collection is resident in
the place, you know, with the baseball cards
from the Negro leagues, if that's important
to you, or to presidential personal papers.
To have it be taken that seriously and have
it count towards the larger picture is,
I know that that's fuzzy curriculum,
but we see that it makes broad impacts
for more specific curriculum
goals and objectives.
Somebody mentioned earlier, I think
it was Kathleen, about creative works
in the existing collections,
but the other aspect of this is
that not only does creating this primary
source, if you engage your students
with the actual collections in terms of
creating it, not only is there the opportunity
for getting them to help pull
those together and talking
about how those artistic works can be part
of the larger story of a personal narrative,
but one thing that we're seeing more
and more of is classroom projects
that take the existing oral history
and turn it into something else.
A starting off point for
creating works themselves.
There have been a couple of
fantastic examples of that.
In just a minute I'm going to play this
clip, but I want to give a few examples
so that you have a sense
of what I'm talking about.
Several years ago, there was
a group of students working
on the Philadelphia Student Mural Project,
and they had previously done some murals
with some veterans and there was an effort to
specifically do a mural with Tuskegee Airmen.
And we got connected to them through
a variety of different sources
and were able to provide for them a workshop.
And what they did was they did, targeted
oral histories with Tuskegee Airmen,
and then did the mural, and
about the airmen's experience.
And what we heard from all participants
from all sides, including the artists,
the teaching artists that
helped them create the mural,
was that it was a much more engaged in-depth.
And every step of the process, it
was essentially a better product,
whether you were looking at it from an artistic
standard or from meeting curricular objectives
or from connecting people in communities
that it, by using the oral history process
through the Veteran's History Project as
a vehicle for deriving greater meaning,
they were able to far exceed their expectations
for what they were trying
to accomplish artistically.
And it's just really cool
to hear all about that.
This is another great example, and we're
going to try our best to play it for you,
is this three minute clip of one of
two of the honorable mention videos
that were awarded honorable mentions in the
White House Film Festival this past year
who showcased the student works
showcasing their VHP activity.
So, it's a great example not of how
students can turn this into something else,
but what the impact is for the
students and for the community.
So, bear with me.
I'm going to try and play this.
>> Dear students, thank you
for your kindness to Ed.
Thank you for the grand Veteran's
Day card that you sent him.
I'm looking at it right now.
I've placed it with Ed's high
school graduation picture.
The flag that was on his coffin
in a photo of him in the service.
Thank you for letting Ed be a part
of the Veteran's History Project
at the Library of Congress.
Ed enjoyed so very much when he would
meet and speak with you young people.
It was an honor for him.
Ed passed away on December 20th, 2012.
He had a rough year health-wise, but the best
occasions he attended were those involving
young people.
Very truly yours, Adele S. Fabish.
>> I admire this boy because he's
got his future to look forward to.
>> Hi. My name's Ty.
I'm part of the Harlem Veteran Project.
I currently have a question
on what type of aircraft were
on his carrier during World War II.
So, I'm going to be heading over to
his place, see if he can identify some
of the aircraft I'm going to print out for him.
>> Mr. Terreberry, what does it mean
to you knowing that Ty's working on it,
knowing that he hopes to get into the
Navy, or is heading down into the Navy?
>> I admire Ty for what he's doing.
>> I honestly think I don't deserve
some of the things that he just said.
It's, I just feel like that I'm
just a regular high school student
that has so many big aspirations.
>> No, you're not.
>> And --
No, you're not.
You're an exceptionally young man with a future,
and we need more people, more people like you.
>> The Crabb family.
I worked on Mr. Crabb's documentary
last year, and unfortunately,
he passed away around three weeks ago.
In lieu of flowers or any other
sort of donations to the family,
they decided to donate it to the project.
So, I'm going right now to personally
thank them not only for that,
but for all of the other
contributions in my life.
>> These are his shirts.
>> He wore black jeans and flannel shirts --
>> Every day of his life.
>> So, we thought it'd be good.
>> I think for any student going through
this project, there are certain life lessons
that you don't get out of a book.
>> Both of my grandparents have
been a huge part of my kid's lives,
and my daughter is only four
years old and my son is two.
So, the memories that they have
with him will fade over time.
At his visitation, to hear his voice
playing in the background just showed me
that he's just still here with all of us.
>> Dear veterans, I write this letter in hopes
that someone somewhere will hear this call.
Students from Harlem High School will
continue to hear and record your stories.
For one of the greatest accomplishments a high
school student can have is documenting our
hero's history.
Lastly, know that as long as you bravely
serve our nation, we will always be listening.
Yours truly, Michael Fenters.
[ Music ]
>> Thanks for bearing with me, everyone.
I hope that you feel as I
do that it was worth it.
I just think that's a really great example
of the students really pouring their
personal energy into this effort.
That particular program is both happening
in the classroom an as an extracurricular,
which is a model we've seen in lots
of classrooms across the country.
Either examples include schools where they're
doing it almost like a yearbook model.
I'm so glad you enjoyed it.
It's nice to see the feedback.
Thanks, Cindy and Christina.
They're doing models very similar to that
where there's a portion of it that happens
in a classroom setting and
then it's an afterschool club,
almost like a yearbook would be where
they produce a coffee table book
that then goes out to the entire community.
I've seen other examples where they do it
similar to a big read where, at the end,
everyone gets an opportunity to select a
vignette, and then they create a documentary
that the whole community watches
through a series of events.
Somebody earlier talked about teachers looking
for ways to connect students with curriculum
and build the skill sets
needed for real world tasks.
What we're seeing with these kinds of
outputs is the ability to take advantage
of using authentic material
primary sources to engage with them
on exactly that, on these kinds of rural tasks.
So, one of the things that we
wanted to be able to -- oh, yeah.
It is similar to the Paper Clips Project.
That's true.
One of the things that we
just were able to produce
with the Oral History Association is they,
in their wonderful way, call it a pamphlet
which I just love because it's 95 pages long,
but there is, and you can get this for $15
on Amazon and on Barnes and Noble.
It's called "Doing Veterans Oral History".
But there is an entire chapter, about 30
pages, devoted to educators and to students,
if you want something a little bit more than
what we have available through our field kit
on our website and our 15 minute video.
This gives you the opportunity to go through it
or hand it to your students with that scholarly
or academic lens of the best
practices of oral history.
That section that's geared
just towards educators,
I'm able to provide for you
as a text PDF for free.
You don't have to purchase the
whole book, but if you're interested
in the whole book, it is really nice.
And like I said, you can purchase that on Amazon
or Barnes and Noble, or if you would like,
you can get it from us, just the
educator's portion, and we'll be offering
that in a few different packages
in a coming year.
But that's something I can offer to
you for participating in this now.
And, again, it's a student resource, in a way,
to add on to the existing
resources we have on our website.
Just wanted to point that out to you.
You can also find that information about
it on Oral History Association's website.
The other thing that we have started this
year through a generous gift from Bill
and Buffy Cafritz's Family Foundation
is a campaign specifically aimed
at recording the stories of World War II
veterans from the Washington Metropolitan area.
Bill Cafritz passed away last year,
and he had served in World War II
and had been awarded a Purple Heart;
but it turned out that very few people
in his life actually knew about that
because he didn't talk about it.
And, so, it was just sort of a wonderful
cinergy of things come together for making sure
that DC World War II veterans
understood we wanted them to be part
of this historic milestone of the first 100,000.
Get your stories in there before you're
not part of that first milestone.
The reason I'm sharing it here is because
we're hoping to turn this into a template
that other communities could
use, and we'll have elements
of it available for people to customize.
So, in a situation like the Harlem Veteran's
History Project, it might make a lot of sense
for them to sort of plug and play and use some
of the tools that we're creating around this.
So, I just kind of wanted to
bring that to your attention.
We're also finding that the whole
notion of our history's future is
in your hands is something that's really
resonating with high school students
who have seen this campaign
and images from this campaign.
So, I think I'm right in time to
leave plenty of time for questions.
So, please, fire away.
>> Okay. Monica, I've also received
a couple questions separately.
So, I'll ask you the first couple
while other people ask their questions.
You ready?
So, first question is: Are there particular
resources from the Veteran's History Project
that appear to be, you know, more
proper downloads by teachers?
Are you able to see any patterns there?
>> That's a great question.
I think historically across the
board, World War II has been something
that folks are really gravitating
towards, but in the past couple of years,
we've seen a real shift towards Vietnam.
We're actually the centerpiece of the Vietnam
Veterans Memorial Foundation Curriculum Guide.
They offer lots of tools in general for
teaching Vietnam, and we're used as,
what I believe to be really
essential, enriching part of that.
So, I know that that's a broad brush
stroke, but that's what we've seen so far.
>> Awesome.
And that is Christina also has a question.
She asks: Can you walk us
through teachers/students,
what they would actually submit
interviews and other primary sources?
In other words, how would they go about
sort of participating in the process?
>> Absolutely.
It's the "how to participate" page that I
showed you on that 15 minute video as well
as our field kit are really
essential in doing that,
and you can find all of those
through the homepage.
But the process is pretty straightforward.
If you're going to do an interview,
you simply use the required forms.
You set up the conversation with the
veteran, and you record an interview.
One interview per recordable
media, 30 minutes or longer.
And with all the forms packaged together,
each recording with each set of forms,
and you submit them to the Library of Congress.
I'm going to keep it broad there because
those resources are wildly accessible off
the homepage.
But, Christina, if you have any
specific questions beyond that,
I'd be happy to answer them.
I see that Cindy Witch asks:
Are the collections growing,
and do you find the veterans are
willing to share their personal items?
Really great question, Cindy.
The collections are growing.
We get about 100 collections
per week on average.
More when you might expect teachers
to be sending us troves of them.
Unless when there's lulls in schedules,
but on average, about 100 per week.
And veterans are willing to
share their personal items,
especially when they know they're
coming to the Library of Congress.
It can be daunting to face
the whole original question.
You know, why do they need our originals, but,
you know, there are floods, fires, I mean,
I hate to go to the super dramatic right
away, but there are lots of reasons that we're
in the business of protecting originals.
And what we've been finding is that families
actually really appreciate the opportunity
to know that the originals are here
and being used for research purposes.
Sorry. I just want to try and
read through the questions.
[inaudible] Go for it.
>> I'm sorry.
I had one more question for you.
I'm getting some questions separately.
This is more of a personal one which is: How did
you get involved with Veteran's History Project?
What is your kind of connection to this project?
>> Man, I hated answering that question.
I'm involved in the project,
really, I stumbled into it.
My work here started with a small project aimed
at illuminating the collections of the Library
of Congress for K through 12 audiences, and
they needed someone to help do that specifically
with the Veteran's History
Project as it was growing in 2005.
And, so, I was moved over to
work on that and then never left.
My husband is a veteran.
His family members are veterans.
My background, I am half Indian.
I was born in India, and I don't have
a connection sort of through my family
of origin, but my adopted family for sure.
And just got really engaged with the whole
notion of why oral history is important
and how it connects people to
the real sources of information
and how it is magically gives voice to every
perspective, validating every perspective.
So, I'll leave it there.
>> That's great.
Linda also asks a question.
Can family members access recordings and other
artifacts after they are submitted, and if so,
how long a turnaround would they
expect before they would be available?
>> After long work days in the middle of the
week, I'm so impressed with these questions.
It's really great.
Yes. Family members can access the recordings.
Anyone can access them.
About over 15,000 of our over 98,000
collections are available digitized online.
For the rest of those collections
that we haven't yet been able
to digitize, and that will be a long process.
I'm certainly not promising that
all of them will be digitized,
but family members can come here to the
Library of Congress and they can view them.
In fact, we have a couple of families that do
that on an annual basis to celebrate birthdays,
they come, and sometimes they
continue to contribute to a collection
as they find more letters or more
photographs and they turn that into an event,
which is really a lovely thing to see.
The turnaround for processing a collection that
is sent in, and I'll just put in a plug here not
to send collections via the USPS.
We can't take collections through the
postal service because they get fried
by the specific screening process,
but collections that are sent here typically
get processed within four to six weeks
for acknowledgment of receipt and then between
four and six months for actually being able
to come and see it and do research,
essentially, or to use the collection.
If a large family, you know, more than
two or three people is going to come,
which we do have happen, the appointment is made
in our information center, or if it's for more
of a research use, the appointment
is made with our reference specialist
for the American Folk Life Center reading room.
And that's where they get served the collection.
And as I mentioned before, researchers
use these collections every week.
We're serving them to serious
researchers and family members alike
in the American Folk Life
Center reading room and also
in the Veteran's History
Project information center.
>> Okay. We probably have time for
one more question before we wrap up,
and I've got another one for you, Monica.
In terms of teacher use, you know, the
question about access raising, you know,
copyright issues, are all these
resources that you find online?
Are these, you know, generally
free for teachers to use and,
or do they have to worry
about copyrighting issues?
>> Copyright is not an issue
for teachers to use.
The veterans and the interviewers actually
retain copyright based on our release forms.
However, our release forms are specific
to us sharing the collections
for educational purposes.
So, if you're going to, you know, turn it
into the latest blockbuster HBO script,
it's incumbent upon you to go
ahead and get if copyright.
We don't adjudicate that, but it
is up to you to make that happen.
But for teachers, there are
no copyright problems,
and teachers all across the country
use the collections all the time.
>> Monica, that's great.
We're just about bumping up on ten minutes till.
Do you have any final words for us, or
do you want, should we just wrap it up?
>> Actually, I would say just one point to
consider when you're looking at this collection
when you're thinking about the
Veteran's History Project is that 60,
according to a peer research survey,
62 percent of the American public
is immediately related to a veteran.
That's, and they define that as
spouse, parent, sibling, or child.
That doesn't include grandparents,
aunts and uncles, or cousins.
And, so, if that's the number for 62 percent,
if you expand that to that level of family
or to how we make our families
today, I think we get lost
in the numbers about the 1 percent that serve.
That may be true for the current conflict, but
when you think about the divide and the gap
between the veterans and the veteran
population and the general population,
that divides actually much smaller.
So, I just implore you to think about,
as we're headed into Veteran's Day,
as we're headed into the holidays,
think about the veteran in your life,
think about the veteran in your community.
This is something you can do with your students.
This is also something you can do to enrich your
personal experience, and I hereby deputize all
of you as ambassadors of the project.
Thanks so much for your time today.
>> Monica, thank you so much.
I can see all these thank
you's pouring in the chat.
Add my thank you to that.
It was a wonderful session.
Very informative and very moving as well.
For everybody on the call,
thank you for joining us.
If you look up at the screen, there
are some final information for you.
We'd love to have your feedback
on these sessions.
So, there's a link there.
You can click right on that link
and take a quick survey for us.
The feedback really helps us
to just kind of get better
and serve you teachers, serve you as teachers.
Also, for those wanting a certificate,
you are eligible to get a certificate
for one instructional hour for this session.
You will receive an e-mail within five business
days with directions to access that certificate.
Finally, as we've mentioned several
times, this session was recorded,
so you can go back and watch it again.
You will see it online.
Please tell your colleagues, your family
members, to go on and watch it as well because,
you know, we can sort of spread the
world beyond this particular group.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.